JENNY BROWN: We've
covered upload speed
hiccups for large files.
But what about when
it's time to read?
On this episode of
Cloud Storage Bytes,
you'll need your
reading glasses,
because we're talking
large file downloads.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We've all been there, staring
at our watch wondering
how much longer it's going
to take for that large file
to move from cloud storage
to the virtual machine
where computation occurs.
Even if it's only two
minutes, that's an eternity
as far as we're concerned,
especially when we're
paying for that computing
power during our download.
Ouch.
When looking at
our options here,
we might recall that gsutil
saved the day for our uploads.
But that doesn't seem to be
the case for our downloads.
We even found that curl
outperforms gsutil here.
But why?
And just when we thought
we had it all figured out,
luckily, I'm on the case.
And as it turns out, the
default settings for gsutil
don't work particularly well
with large file downloads.
This is because these
default settings
are designed to spread downloads
across four threads using
one process.
We should be able to
improve the performance
by limiting the
number of threads
and forcing the system to use
multiple processes instead.
For a quick recap, processes
are instances of execution,
while threads are
individual executions that
run inside of a process.
We want more processes, but
each focused on only one task.
So first up, limiting
the number of threads.
To do this, there is
a command line option
to specify the thread count.
We'll go ahead and
reduce it to one.
With this small change, we've
improved the performance.
But we're still not at the
level that curl is showing when
we're fetching through HTTP.
So next up, forcing
multiple processes.
To do this, we're going
to have a throwback moment
to a previous
Cloud Storage Bytes
where we discussed a
parallel composite upload.
Now, it's time for parallel
or sliced downloads, which
we can trigger by
telling gsutil to use
a certain number of components.
So to recap-- decreasing
the number of threads
and increasing the
number of components
can work together to
dramatically improve
your download speed.
There's plenty more to come
about optimizing performance,
but that's for another episode.
If you want to know more
about downloading large files,
check out the links
in the description.
And as always, don't forget
to subscribe, give us alike,
and tell us what you want
to learn about Google Cloud
Storage.
Thanks for joining us for this
quick bite of cloud storage.
See you next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]